[Music]
oh
this week in feminism
[Music]
so then i came back from the tattoo
parlor and my boyfriend didn't like my
spacers or my nose
piercing or my bowl cut
really
dating someone else
a patriarchy
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
placenta all right good morning everyone
that was disgusting ahoy everybody i
don't know what is in there but thanks
guys i hope it makes me ill
okay
welcome to the show everyone uh if as uh
always we have a lot of fun people here
and there's a live show monday through
thursday 10 a.m we're on rumble we're on
all kinds of places where you can find
uh podcasts we're my mug club uh youtube
of course we might get thrown off so go
to everything else i just mentioned
and other than that how about a question
of the day how did you celebrate
mother's
birthing persons day yeah that's right
it's a whole new thing go ahead and
leave your comment i drove to detroit
and [ __ ] on my mom's grave
that was the way it was the way to make
it work i feel this
i'm just glad that men can take
everything away from women so as long as
you can
and the best uh best person
uh who has the best uh response of what
you did on birthing person's day you get
a free cat bath from gerald day
so it's gonna be very exciting
it's gonna be good speaking of which uh
speaking of people on maternity leave
who shouldn't be uh gerald b is here
because gerald a is not
still at home
uh breastfeeding his
son and then we
chest feed it chest feeding i mean right
because well he doesn't use his really
he's got the
the de niro yeah
push it in twist to lock
oh and of course we have i'm going to
call him psychologist kevin
morton sir hey how are you welcome to
the show better now how are you good we
got casey basum good morning hey good
morning and of course tim the tool man
as always good morning dave hey good
morning to you my friend and a very
special ahoy to one of my good friends
and favorite people
crawdaddy thank you david good to see
you thank you for coming kind of a bare
bones crew today yeah we got it very
slim how many kids did gerald have do we
know i mean he's been gone a while i i
believe he had just one but boy his
maternity leave is something special
isn't it it really is yeah he really
takes advantage of a situation
if a woman did it he'd be he'd be mouthy
about it that's true but boy can he
hypocritic at home can he can't stay
there
probably
sitting around and talking to his
newborn misquoting scripture
[Laughter]
very exciting stuff unless uh more
exciting news so leave your comments it
helps our algorithm and uh stephen
crowder he's not in today's doing
something special for you guys i think
you're gonna enjoy when when he puts
that together
and uh we are gonna be in tulsa this
saturday so that's pretty sweet
right there go head to
louderwithcrowder.com
and you can also see me solo may 29th at
fuel fest in gaylord michigan
[Music]
gaylord
michigan
what is fuel fest uh fuel fest is it's a
new thing i guess they won uh
a lawsuit
against the state for forcing them to
shut down over mask mandates
so this is like a celebration they're
having okay as kind of a uh middle
finger to the governor whitmer
sweet and i'm happy to be proud of it
i'm proud to be a part of it
yeah i flubbed my words because i used
to do drugs
we also uh also the 27th and 28th of may
i will be at big ales in emily minnesota
and i'm on a new app that i just want to
talk about real quick it's called shout
out there's really cool people on it you
have like dean kane you have there's a
have you seen it at all he's hunky he is
hunky yeah america's hunky is superman i
i've always and the most one that can
walk the most
but there's a lot of great people on
there and you can get a happy birthday
yours are the best thank you they're so
fun to watch i really like doing them
for people
so i did a lot of fun mother's day ones
and uh yeah go on there it's only a
couple bucks and i'd like to wish you a
happy birthday
or birthing person for happy birthing
persons
day because the world is smart
speaking of
everything makes sense
oh
honestly when i think about my mom
glad she's dead like why would you want
to live in this time
i can't yeah i wouldn't even know how to
explain it to her i'd be like yeah it's
it's yeah i can give you even people
that have only been gone a few years
they if they were to come alive today
they wouldn't believe it no at all yeah
like if you died in like 07.
you wouldn't know what to do you'd be
like whatever get martin luther king
coming back no somebody just a few years
you know even martin luther king would
come back and go hey guys not what i
meant that's right exactly
just disappointed
i watch a lot of netflix i'm not going
to lie do you do you watch any you know
i i don't normally but i just did we
were just just talking about this casey
now we're just talking about a movie i
watched on there had never seen the
other guys can't believe it so funny
so quotable they just my wife was
howling that's that's not a movie the
gals would normally go to but it was a
lot of fun i think the rock and sam
jackson jumping to their death is
probably the funniest thing aim for the
butcher aim for the bushes what were you
thinking
so it wasn't even an awning
homeless people just keep having sex in
will ferrell's prius
such a good movie i know i've ruined two
parts but not the film i promise it's
punchline after punchline i need to know
who that woman is it's my wife no i need
to know who is she
why do you would not accept yeah that
ever meant
anyway basically how did you get that i
don't get it he's a pimp named gator
that's my netflix that's that's what i
did yeah well there's a lot of things on
there now about how people tend to get
uh
you know all sorts of jams if you will
on dating apps
and
i guess i've i've never been a dating
app person uh i i met married through
the dating app here yeah i never dated
in the dating app era so
there's a new documentary out there it's
still very popular i guess it's been on
it for a little while but it's still
like in the top ten and i i finally
watched it it's called the tinder
swindler let's take a look i only miss
you anyway
when i first talked with simon
immediately we had a bond
he was smart and funny and very
impulsive
i shared my whole heart with him
and then he asked me if i wanted to
travel with him i'm on a private jet
i was like
he took me to a five-star hotel he said
we had a special connection it felt like
stepping into a movie and then the
middle of the night
[Music]
he said there was something he wants to
tell me
he said he has threats against him
he needs to borrow cash
twenty thousand dollars thirty thousand
one hundred forty thousand dollars his
life depended on me
that's when police tell me
the man i loved was never real
wow well when a billionaire asks for 20
000
that might be a hint
[Laughter]
what's with all the drone
city shots now that's the new screen
wipe if you noticed boom and we're going
over the top of the buildings boom it
really is it just means you couldn't
afford footage that's right you had to
buy it all for like the mail
he asked me he's billionaire he we went
and planed and he asked me for 100 000 i
was like sure i loaned to you
and then he it turned out his name is
not dan
wow
good story
where is the set what what was that
accent uh
stupidville okay
i really have no i couldn't tell by the
multiple cityscape yeah screen wipes i
guess he travels all over the place yeah
the screen the screenpipe seems to be uh
a shot from ninja turtles but otherwise
i don't know
it is different recognition you
recognize the manhole covers yes
yes exactly
well there's actually another one coming
out now um this is inter this is about
uh an app it's actually for uh men who
who are dating in uh the homosexual
community
uh and this one is called the the
grinder denier
you can get a little bit of anything you
want on grindr
from fetishes to admirers
to people who claim to have never been
on it
all right so get this i was walking
through downtown chicago bird sanctuary
3 a.m in the morning you know like
normal folk do
and this guy just pops out of nowhere he
says that if i don't give him ten
thousand bucks he's gonna tell my entire
family that we uh met up on grindr and
had a
intercourse in the parakeet den so did
you end up paying him i had to somehow
he had made this entire grinder profile
that only i knew the password to
so i went on to grindr because i thought
it was an app about
hard work you know motivational like you
know like grinding it out yes i am brian
stelter
the real brian stelter but you guys
aren't going to use my real name right
and you pinky promise that you blur out
my face
great
anyway next thing you know this guy
messages me about meeting him on a
construction site to show me how hard he
could could work me
it seemed legit now i can talk about how
i keep getting robbed in all male
swingers clubs next thing you know i'm
giving him 500 to do unmentionable
things here comes the meat choo choo
hey i need my money back someone needs
to find this blackmailer make him give
me back my ten thousand dollars
ha
there's a reminder
i think i might know where he is i'm
gonna go have a word with him uh
a whole mouthful
yeah i paid him 500 for oral services
rendered because i appreciate hard work
how is that prostitution what are you
nuts what would i go on a show admitting
to paying for a male prostitute
only i knew the password only i had
those pictures of my penis yeah you got
to tell them my masseuses to stop lying
over here that's perjury slander you
even talk to them have you
make sure you cut them out of the
special
me gay i don't think so actually i'm
extremely heterosexual
but i do go to the gay clubs only
because i like the buffets
yeah that's great and everything but
what about when you were found
unconscious at a lgbtq nightclub called
the rest area i went there because i
heard they had marvelous stuffed crust
pizza it turned out they didn't
i was in the bathroom when a flame
twirler knocked me out with one of his
batons and then a diana ross
impersonator stole my crocs
it was the worst night of my life
i mean
yeah i guess
[Music]
haunting stuff
well they need a nap too dave i mean
come on yeah it's true i just it's a
shame people get ripped off on them
i guess brian seltzer just uses it to
get like get food but you know you never
know you never know what you're going to
walk into
speaking of uh
filter yeah poor guy i mean really he's
just a he's a good
good-looking anchor
this is true yeah
handsome
charismatic
yeah where would you think he'll land
after cnn
we know that's coming soon
the white house and push back into the
ocean
[Laughter]
press secretary
i think you're right
where else yeah the girls is gonna go
that's exactly where they go
like well yeah they just get recycled
though yeah yeah yeah
or you know
white house we just need you to
embarrass us and be the secretary of
paint your nails yeah
speaking of cnn
jim acosta i don't know if you know this
is a hero
on saturday jim acosta tweeted something
terribly bigoted and he doesn't even
know it
he wrote this ran into an afghan refugee
in the elevator today he was delivering
groceries
didn't know which buttons to push so i
helped
must have been new as he got off the
elevator he thanked me
and said i am afghan
i said good luck and welcome to america
he smiled
he's on his way
how did he know which button to push
right how is he helping
he didn't know the numbers yeah
how does he know what room to find
i'll take uh [ __ ] that never happened
alex oh you win 500. yeah
that's unbelievable he can't figure out
one through ten but then he's like it's
upstairs he's like this is 438 where
they ordered
this entire thing how does acosta know
he was a refugee
unbelievable
these people he can work at gps but he
gets an elevator and he's like i don't
know
what is this time box do i travel
is it
also arabic numerals
our number system is based on arabic
numerals that's right if he's arabic
he's gonna know what it means he's not
gonna stand there confused
like he just he just got to the country
illegally i guess according to acosta
and uh
what got a job at doordash
and just sat and just sat confused yeah
he knows how to count his tips and he
corrected acosta explained to him that
it's a lift in the uk not an elevator
yes
you seem
it's like he had been here and just had
a slight accent
yeah he had a license to do it right
license to drive but
numbers
yeah he was able to read an odometer but
boy when it came to that elevator really
threw him off acosta just saw brown guys
i got it
the numbers are literally stacked on on
the wall yeah he's like oh man the one
through ten things
there is no thirteen i don't know what
to do i don't know i've never measured a
fence
this is terrible
it's no way
acosta not only made up a ridiculous
story to virtue signal but he made it
horribly bigoted so good for you acosta
you're an idiot
[Laughter]
cnn actually uh you know their plus app
it officially did shut down after uh one
month which is really
that's special numbers that's amazing
but after 30 days i started them
watching them lower the price because at
first it was like it's only nine bucks
then they're like it's 299 then they're
like we'll give you a dollar
[Laughter]
and there was questions as to whether or
not uh some of their programming uh
would live on
look at that
inside sources at cnn leaked to us that
they had a ton of programming in the
works that'll never see the light of day
some of them even sitcoms
here are seven plus one failed cnn
plus pilots
[Music]
you forgot to find in the chamber
there's always one in the chamber
crawdaddy can you help me out we're
going to do this number seven
to hire a predator
because there's a lot of them there
if you look it up it's
wow
that's number six crawdaddy how i met
your bi-curious zither
what
that's a
i understand it say bye it's a
bi-curious mother father parents okay
queer
it's just i'm not making it up that's
literally
definite everything's stupid yes that's
correct uh five brian stelter actually
would have had a new show on there it's
called a straight eye for the queer guy
[Laughter]
i thought he just liked the stuffed
crusts
[Laughter]
number four crawdaddy naked and afraid
kids edition what
unbelievable that's not good programming
no i don't think so i mean they you know
they're just throwing stuff against the
walls of the sticks
i just realized
it's not a wall all right so uh number
let's see where we're at number three
cuomo brothers the bachelorette
stromboli island
they're not they're not bachelors but
they're
they certainly pretend they are for the
show number two crawdaddy
al sharpton learns to read
and now that the network's gone under
he's never going to
that was going to be a big thing for him
poor guy yeah i know right for him he's
just never going to never get those is
he a better reader than biden though
yeah
yeah i think so i mean vine's got to be
in the title yeah brian's got an
earpiece and still
he can't even repeat back words salute
the troops
they don't they're stop it lloyd bridges
[Laughter]
lord
um
this says and number one uh don lemon
actually has his version of shark tank
it's called uh shart taint
and that's where instead of pitching
ideas
he just pinches your taint it's kind of
different
oh we also do have a plus one what was i
thinking what yeah that's right there's
always one there's always one the sticky
situation room with jeffrey tubin
i'm i'm sad that this isn't going to
make the air how about you yeah
i'm waiting for that stinger we've got
to get out of this i i wouldn't i would
at least watch y'all sharks
to read
[Laughter]
[Music]
you'll forgot the van in the chamber
there's always one in the chamber al
sharpton
good guy
hook it on pogonics i originally had l
sharpton uh verse food
so that'd be fun if we got heavy again
i miss heavy owl
it's funnier
any rhymed better
it's true like whenever every pound he
lost he rhymed a little bit and for a
guy who's not good at reading
great at rhyming
that's pretty good
yeah well he's not grandstanding on tv
like he does in the streets that's true
yeah yeah that is very true
i think he's more real on the streets
and on cnn when he's reading news he's
like me
[Laughter]
all right
[Laughter]
we're talking about this a man in texas
has an outstanding warrant for burglary
of a building
he was caught on camera at a home
removing items from a garage before
pulling out the lawnmower and knowing
both the front and backyards
here it is
look at this monster
what are you doing i'm cutting your lawn
i know
what's he burgling
he i think he just got tired of their
long grass and was like i'm doing it
myself
oh he didn't trim that's what it is
though
had he edged it wouldn't have hit him
yeah
they're watching the footage like he
he's actually doing a good job
is he gonna repair the picket fence yes
that was his next thing he also stole a
hammer and put it back
he's in this painting the house and
next day he comes back to shingle the
roof
this criminal well according to the new
york post this is the guy so clearly he
was i'm guessing uh
a pcp
because i think either that or meth
because he's doing a good job
clearly he's high i'm just guest
guessing by the bird's nest on top of
his head
i think there's a woodpecker in it
yeah i put my money on meth yo for i
just unaware that it was night time an
inappropriate time to be mowing it but
that seems like a good time if you're on
meth to cut your lawn
you know it's not a daytime activity
when you're when you're on crank and as
you know dave a lot of these
neighborhoods not real good homeowners
associations no they're not that's
probably this guy's just trying to take
it upon himself he's like nobody showed
up to the homeowner association
it's just me and my bag of meth yeah he
probably thought it was his house yeah
it's true he's freaking [ __ ]
where he wanted it to be
yeah it's true she's gonna go and kill
everyone i was gonna put in an offer man
i want you to move let's make it pretty
the officers arrived at the home and
chased the suspect who uh pulled the
lawnmower behind him before ditching in
an alley nearby
there you go that's it's him again
and continuing the escape it's important
to note uh in the full tape the guy
actually doesn't ever steal anything and
i'm not sure if he was even suing the
lawnmower or just scared and carrying
the lawnmower with him until it was too
heavy to hop a fence it's tough to get
away with a self-propelled lawnmower
pulling against you it really is yeah i
can't get a lot of momentum there's no
way he let go of it where he wasn't just
holding it holding the handle down
[Laughter]
it's spinning the wheels just
he's got a leaf blower in one hand
he just forgot he had it i know
getting a foreplay to a home invasion
it's just you know we're going to make
it nice this time yeah that's true yeah
he's waiting for his friends he's like
we are going to tie everybody up but you
know let's let's make it nice
we'll go inside
i love how he gingerly takes the the
fence picket and just puts it where he
is i was going to line it up but that's
good enough yeah yeah yeah it's like he
didn't just kick it out of the way and
continue to mow now he put it put it
where it belongs
yeah the there's a kidnapping and uh
also they left some feng shui
i mean the room looks gorgeous but it
feels wonderful yeah it's really yeah i
hate it
yeah i had no idea how big it could look
you saw the video he actually put gas in
the mower
[Laughter]
did he check the oil
i don't know
he probably just huffed it
yeah so he's taking it out
he's putting gas in that's amazing
he's a gentleman
he brought his own it's not even theirs
hey price of gas mileage this is very
expensive he's like if i'm going to cut
your lawn i'm going to do it right
it's four dollars a gallon please
could he just didn't pick up the
trimming so it's a crime yeah
oh well i say this man is not a criminal
and if you want to break into my uh
garage and cut my lawn
uh once a week
i'll give you like 30 bucks
[Laughter]
let's see if somebody ought to tip them
yeah i would just walk out and be like i
don't know what's wrong with you but
here
and thank you these are times when it
would be a blast to be the judge
come on
when you have fun with that i love it
i'd be like have you thought about
making it a business as opposed to a
crime
i'm gonna give you community service to
do my lawn for the rest of the season
you're doing a good job yeah you do very
nice have you considered doing this for
me and the district attorney there
bailiff how's your law yes
this is some really nice the courthouse
actually needs some gardening municipal
buildings this is all going to look good
oh man rob's going to take the fun out
though
oh that's true
[Laughter]
i can't do math and just melt anybody's
line like that's about somebody else's
lawn
yeah i'm sure like the fourth lawn once
it's too much meth it's just a train
wreck
you see like the crop circles in the
front
that's how the crop circles actually
yeah he's just cutting himself the
lawnmower blade i don't like this guy i
don't know just tip him and tell him to
leave i'm not going out there
let him do what he would
he's the batman of home maintenance
yeah he's really he's oh he's great at
mowing until he's picking invisible
mites off his skin
other than that
yeah a plus
yeah they should give him a nice haircut
get him a little truck
for his for his
friend's lawnmower or whatever house
that was good for him i say
good for you innocent cheers absolutely
well
i'm sure you guys have heard about this
there was a roe v wade leak
[Music]
and it continues to escalate
and naturally celebrities have been more
than eager
to share their expert opinions
look at that we got george takei
roseanne
arquette and carrot top
i think that was kathy griffin
yeah i'm sure it is oh i'm sure it's
getting
mad
she looks like a used mop oh no she
should change her name to carrot bottom
oh
anyway
and kathy
griffin
are among a host of celebrities
sorry dry heaved who have spoken out in
fact it looks like michael moore already
has a new movie out called row v and me
oh look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i
love
food
[Music]
and i know
it's true the commercials are seldom
what they seem
that's why i make reviews i prefer food
for you
i'll try anything once but usually way
more than once
especially things filled with
it's just michael moore singing about
food david yeah that
that wasn't anything to do with rover's
weight and nothing absolutely nothing
should he even eat like that doesn't he
have doesn't he he's got f-type 2 right
at minimum
yeah how does he have two legs as you
would say i don't know
i i i guess
it's interesting that that's the uh the
trailer for the movie and it has nothing
to do with roe v wade no none
but i guess flint water is good for
something
[Laughter]
that's where he lives and also i am from
michigan and we have apologized for
michael moore
on many occasions
okay
i'm just uh i'm not a fan i liked roger
and me
and then after that it was just uh
a lot of that was fake too was it really
that's too bad
remember when you went to the gross
point yacht club to try to find roger
from gm
oh yeah i do yeah he was never a member
there
was it not no it was just a big symbol
of opulence and wealth that he's sitting
in there having a cigar and you know
that they would go and just looking
around oh he's not here come on i mean
that's just it's cheap theatrics right
and what's funny is it's not like gross
point is known to be rich for michigan
and the detroit area it's upper middle
class anywhere else in the country
and all the way to lower middle class
depending on what part you live in
you know like that it's not like there's
normal boats there there are some giant
yachts and stuff but they don't really
belong to people well it is the place
where
i mean the equivalent of today's gates
and musk you know live along ford's and
dodge families fisher body all these
industrialists right oh yeah yeah but
that's not the case anymore no but
lakeshore is beautiful yeah i have
friends that live there oh the houses i
would do drugs in
that's what's great
what's great about rich kids is like a
lot of them have uh
uh no purpose
and absent parents yeah so you just you
just you enjoy their company until one
day they od on one of those yachts
moving on
i wish i was saying but he went in there
looking for him like i'm trying like i'm
trying to find him and he's not here and
he's ducking us what stopped yeah
that's ridiculous yeah like charlton
heston was ducking him on the gun issue
when he got him in his house yeah and
and he was shouting to nobody
making they're making it look like he
ran off like he was avoiding him it's
like a camera shot where it's just all
right get me shouting to you know and
then we'll insert charlton heston
walking away from me
yeah he does these cheap tricks you know
that was one of the first times that i
started questioning any liberal ideology
because that came out when i was in high
school because i was a senior when
columbine happened and i was watching it
and they were blaming kmart for the
bullets that was bought so michael moore
brings in this kid who's in a wheelchair
from columbine and these other people
talking about a soul in the bullets and
it's like we're blaming kmart
which by the way it went out of business
so great job but
why it had nothing to do with kmart it
doesn't matter whether you bought the
bolts
yeah nothing to do with it and that's
what he's trying to do is blame but even
as a teenager you're connecting the dots
and realizing the scam going yeah yeah
all my friends and i were watching were
like this guy's just being an ass and
exploiting a dude in a wheelchair
is completely unnecessary
and it's sad what happened with
columbine
and then we had to have
school drills where we uh
it was uh an alarm system where you
would hide under your desk
that's gonna help oh yeah it was good is
the first time they did it there was the
fire alarm
uh
ugh
were you in school during that i was uh
i was in school during uh that was uh i
mean the drills because uh yeah yeah
they just started the drills
um what happened in 99 you were a fifth
year senior
yes i was a failure senior no that was i
was a first year junior actually at the
time it was 99. okay so yeah they
started doing the drills right after
that and it's like all right we're going
to pull the fire alarm because we don't
have that alarm yet then you get under a
desk and i'm like well what if there's a
fire
and you confuse alarms now it's just
kids burning to death and you're like
well nobody was shot
it was just such a stupid plan so i tell
you what i hear bullets i'm gonna go the
other way plus i got a feeling which
kids are gonna do it and i've always
been nice to him so hopefully it's like
elephant where i'm just gonna walk to my
car and i'm like hey man
remember i gave you drugs all right
and they're shooting all the downed kids
and letting you walk to you yeah that's
all i
not that it's a good thing i'm just
saying sometimes there's weird kids and
if they ask for a cigarette in the boys
room
give them one give it to them yeah you
go here you go buddy
i see you've cut yourself on your wrist
well you guys had to deal with that you
know the school shooting thing we had to
do
the bomb shelter drills where they took
us all down in the basement and they
would shut off the lights
no talking during the nuclear holocaust
you know
so so the whole school could fall on top
of you that's right that's exactly right
pancake onto the student body squish the
kids and a couple times a year we would
do that
really yeah down in the basement what
year they would shut off the lights
carlton elementary school and casino do
you know where that is yeah i do certain
death in there it's there anyway
i think it's still there is it still
there carlton yeah
okay but pieces of it or
the actual school the actual school
between roxbury and lake point people
yeah i know where it is yeah yeah wow
one of the early busing experiments in
the country oh really oh that's right
you said that was one of the first
schools that did it
that's crazy yeah but they would take us
downstairs and then so the kids would
learn not to panic it shut off and it
was pitch black of course that's when
kids would bring squirt guns in and you
know and then the lights would come back
on it was just it was chaos for the 90
seconds the lights were off yeah we did
dumb stuff like we had a uh
we were all drunk at a bar you could
drink it in detroit because it's detroit
and we were all about like 16 17 you
know 18 and
we were like all right whoever drinks
like gives up on shots first
has to go to the pay phone and call on a
bomb threat
and they're like okay
so we're all doing i'm not even worried
about this one
so i i don't have to do it but my buddy
does and he goes across the streets at
the pay phone
and he gets on it he calls it in and
we're like okay like not not realize and
this is a completely fake story uh for
any fbi watching um
but he comes back he's like yeah he did
it we're like oh yeah sure you did
whatever the next day we go to school
there's like robots and bomb sniffing
dogs and they're putting everybody like
over to the bleachers and we're like oh
[ __ ] this just got real wow and we were
all hung over and we're like what are we
gonna do and we're like i guess we just
just watch get the rest of the day off
and we just left
but we didn't realize like the severity
of what we had just done because we did
it like right after columbine
and they were so on like edge because
when you're a kid you don't really get
the severity of anything and i do but
you know we got a day off so there is
i guess i'm saying there's a silver
lining
well pulling a fire alarm was a big deal
that was a big time but you'd do hard
time for that though they would make an
example of you for that one they got
very pissed yeah then they would ask
everybody at the school who did it yeah
but my friends and i want rats
and they know until they start to put
pressure on
all the kids that somebody becomes a rat
yeah as long as it's you and one other
guy you can keep a secret you're like i
have no idea yeah i was in church
nowadays she'd be on camera so
there's no getting away with oh yeah
well every school has cameras now yeah
it's crazy so yeah
well speaking of good kids many
protesters broke out over the weekend
over the roe vs wade league
this one however may have been the most
memorable
[Music]
i mean
she looks great in white at her wedding
but probably not a virgin
i'm killing the baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't think she knew they were dolls
no i guess none of them got her anything
nice for birth person's day
at least she didn't build a fire and
toss them into it
boarded babies being burned and then
used for electricity
i hope they are
she will never get pregnant now
oh no fago's soda will prevent that
give me your feet
[Music]
wow i thought they were vegans
[Laughter]
but on a serious note this mob rule
mindset is exactly what the founding
fathers tried to prevent
here's footage from outside of chief
justice john roberts home as well as
justice uh kavanaugh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's ironic
right with you're drawing hangers in the
street like you think that's the
appropriate tool
this kind of proves how dems don't read
anything since chief justice roberts is
likely siding with the left on this one
look at that supreme court
currently sits at a 6-3 conservative
majority but roberts has more recently
consistently voted with members of the
court that were nominated by democratic
presidents and justice roberts has been
the pivotal majority creating liberals
in many cases
by the way recent polls suggest that the
supreme court leak hasn't moved the
needle at all
this topic has given a voice to black
conservatives however
as more people
notice black lives only seem to matter
when it's convenient
here's a man shutting down a
pro-abortion protest of health care
workers just last week
lives matter or just some black lives
the black lives killed by black men
matter right
yes
the black babies killed in the abortions
clinics matter right
thought so
the black the black officers killed by
that bastard in minnesota that matters
too right
okay but the black babies that are
killed in the abortion clinics don't
matter do they medical people
uh do their lives matter
does the future of our black babies
matter
huh what's up what's up what's up quiet
now aren't they
isn't that the truth though that they
only go
and have black people on their side when
they need them that's right yeah you
know
they lost
yeah the loser doesn't get to mock the
winner no
it's exactly backwards i don't get to
tease the winner that they won and this
victory was 50 years in the making done
appropriately
getting the message out there electing
officials getting officials to appoint
the right justices that are finally 50
years later this kind of thing is coming
back around roe versus wade was all just
you know just tainted from the beginning
it's unbelievable
this was done correctly and they're
gonna trash talk the winners i mean
there's no teeth in it at all well when
you look at it when it just goes from
you know giving the power from the the
government to the states
it's not taking away a right to have an
abortion it's just one of the parts of
the law
which regardless of my opinion or
anybody else's opinion
that
the reaction is absurd right because
it's this direct this direct reaction is
ignorance into believing something that
isn't necessarily true it's this
knee-jerk uneducated reaction and really
so many grotesque ways
i'm eating a baby out of a can well
that's funny yeah i mean it's funny in
in different contexts she's serious
right and like you said they don't read
anything no they're out protesting the
guy who's likely gonna side with them
right they don't get it in macro or
micro they just
they're just all about emotion they're
getting more freedom you imagine being a
neighbor trying to get out of the
driveway
it's like i just guys i i got a job
could you just move your
i would have thought a supreme court
justice would have a nicer crib though i
know i was kind of disappointed didn't
it look like it was off of outer drive
in detroit
is that the chief justice on his front
porch that's weird do you sell dime bags
out of your carpenter house
well let's lighten the mood uh well not
for me but you know
for well for me not this guy and if
you've heard this the man
with a penis on his arm is a new channel
4 british documentary
is real
this is dr dr nick
yeah he's this is real he he claims he
feels like a real man again though
here to help explain is our very own
professor penis
[Music]
all right uh welcome
dr penis oh uh thanks for having me back
uh professor though
oh right uh so
yeah it's been a while yeah thanks for
uh bringing me back on it's my pleasure
honestly it's my pleasure yeah we're
happy to have you oh thanks we need your
clarity yes oh yeah i've heard you guys
got a
kind of a sticky situation here we do we
have a a penis questions yeah and uh an
arm penis if you will uh yep and uh so
uh
this man pat mcgann a british fella uh
ended up with a penis on his arm yeah i
was one of the chief uh
kind of researchers on this project i'll
flip
you by the mic flip this over here so
you guys can see
okay let's take a gander all right
now his penis just fell off
uh yeah from drugs he was uh doing drugs
one day and then uh just plopped right
off and
you know it's a it's a technical term we
use in the research uh professoral
community called kendalling oh okay
i see yeah it's a highly academic term
and then you started a penis transplant
uh yeah so this has been something we've
been working on for a long time but as
you can see here we have
this is where the normal uh you know
human penis would be right right that
fell off now we've got a
his arm up here
and this is where we get the penis parts
um kind of you know like fat or veins or
other [ __ ] you know around his body that
sure like how does one actually grow a
penis from one's father those yeah
pieces from everywhere okay uh i think
we put it on his forearm i mean yeah
like how did like darren asked how does
one grow that you just take those
different fat veins yeah we take that
yeah we take
fat and skin roll it up we put a you
know a vein in the middle we also have
uh
i mean yeah you guys can let's see that
yeah we put it there i see yeah normally
it's pretty pretty functional besides
you know erections or
any other
it can connect to the bladder oh yeah so
we actually took a um
uh it'll be a vein eventually when we
you know since we moved it but we ran a
big tube here
and he hides it under his shirt and we
put some tape tape on it
and connects to where the bladder is
down there
and so yeah then he can
you know it's actually more mobile it's
kind of yeah it's a good way to get
around i would certainly say but no
hydraulics whatsoever uh there's a uh
yeah there'll be a pump now that it's
installed so artificial you know so it's
got kind of more dribbles out i would
assume uh yeah he can uh pump pump it a
little dribble it you know the pumps
there if he
you know wants to become uh tumescent i
see it now is it uh can you function
well with it or is it hurt or how does
that go well it's as you can see it gets
a little technical so we actually have a
piece of the documentary we'll uh we'll
just roll for you guys so you can
yeah okay you know it's not easy having
not worked growing all of your own but
it's better if you feel like i'm lying
again it's better i don't want to just
spell off i mean not good
but it does make certain things
inconvenient when you've got a bonus on
your own
i believe the shaking of me
[Music]
i fell in the land
[Music]
please stop it i'm trying to try to pee
with my penis on
no mail today
[Music]
i can only ride my bicycle at night it's
a law because i can't waver anybody
legally which is okay
it's not oh my god
[Music]
that looked extraordinary sad and
painful i hope he gets it put between
his legs soon yeah it's always tough
watching a patient you know go through
all that it's
also sorry i apologize the diagram was
improperly drawn i forgot he was british
so he updated the oh thank you the teeth
i appreciate that yeah i wasn't sure so
um it will it be transplanted soon uh
yeah it actually as we're speaking uh i
pretty sure it has been transplanted i'm
gonna go follow up and and document that
really yeah that's fantastic yeah well
thank you so much for coming in
professor penis it's great to see you
again yeah no problem all right thanks
for having me this was a blast my
pleasure
[Music]
i'm just glad that we have a medical
research staff
so if he waves to somebody he has to
register that's what he said yeah he can
only ride his bike at night because he
could be a registered sex offender
gotcha
it's it's my
thank you
it's my understanding that uh at a
starbucks once he uh they called his
name and he raised his hand oh
i did three years
very sad
but speaking of penis
piss off youtube
[Music]
foreign